the Queen's coffin will leave in
procession followed by members of the
royal family led by the Queen's four
children including the king
to the sound of minute guns the
procession will carry the queen along
the mall for the last time
before turning right into horse guards
parade
with Big Ben tolling every minute the
procession will cross the great
ceremonial parade ground sight of
trooping the color on the Queen's
official birthday each year
then turning onto Whitehall it will
travel past some of the great offices of
government Downing Street and the
cenotaph which commemorates the nation's
War dead
entering Parliament Square the
procession will turn into New Palace
yard in front of the houses of
Parliament
and then into Westminster Hall where the
Queen's coffin will be taken to Lion
State for the days before her funeral
the procession will make its way into
the oldest part of the Palace of
Westminster led by Heralds and then the
most senior figures in Parliament the
palace and the church of England
the coffin draped with the Royal
Standard will be placed on a raised
platform the catafalk in the middle of
Westminster Hall the king queen consort
and other members of the Royal Family
behind
after a short service led by the
Archbishop of Canterbury the procession
party will leave and members of the
Yeoman of the guard and the household
division will take up positions around
the coffin forming a vigil that will
guard the queen as she lies in state
until her funeral